which of thor's siblings has two academy
awards to their name which spider-man
villain was nominated for two oscars in
one year stick around to learn the only
mcu actors that have received the film
industry's most prestigious award
robert downey jr's first outing as
billionaire tony stark in 2008's iron
man established the character as the
anchor of what would become known as the
infinity saga the film also introduced
audiences to the very first mcu super
villain businessman obadiah stain who
would later adopt his own suit of armor
and become the iron monger stain was
played by jeff bridges who many people
know from projects like the big lebowski
and the tron films after bridge's role
in iron man he would go on to win the
academy award for best actor for his
role as washed up country music singer
otis bad blake in the film crazy heart
bridges was nominated four times prior
to his first win and will go on to
receive two more nominations for his
performances in the western's true grit
and hell or high water gwyneth paltrow
stuck with the mcu franchise for over a
decade playing tony stark's assistant
and love interest pepper potts her final
appearance to date in the mcu was in
2019's avengers in-game where she fought
alongside several other female
superheroes in the film's climactic
battle nearly 10 years prior to paotro
joining the mcu she won the academy
award for best actress for playing viola
de la sept in shakespeare in love the
film also won best picture in several
other oscars
another long-running character
introduced in the first iron man movie
was nick fury the leader of shield who
brought the avengers together played by
samuel l jackson the character has been
a staple of the mcu for years now and
jackson's performance has made him
synonymous with the character as
acclaimed and prolific as jackson is he
has never won an academy award in one of
the acting categories however jackson
did receive an honorary lifetime
achievement academy award for his entire
body of work and contributions to film
at the 2022 oscars
oh i'm sorry did i break your
concentration
i didn't mean to do that please
continue
in the second installment of the iron
man series one of the two villains tony
stark faces off against is weapons
manufacturer justin hammer played by sam
rockwell rockwell has received critical
acclaim for several of his roles but he
received his first academy award in 2018
for his role as jason dixon in three
billboards outside ebbing missouri
rockwell would later earn another
academy award nomination the next year
for his portrayal of president george w
bush and vice
natalie portman played thor's main love
interest jane foster in both the
original thor film and the 2013 sequel
thor the dark world after a nine year
wait portman has returned to the
franchise as mighty thor for the hero's
fourth solo outing thor love and thunder
portman has been nominated for an
academy award three times best
supporting actress for closer and best
actress for black swan and jackie she
won the award for black swan thanks to
her intense portrayal as a perfectionist
ballerina who slowly starts to lose her
sanity while pursuing the lead role in a
production of swan lake
odin the ruler of asgard for all three
entries in the original thor trilogy was
played by legendary actor anthony
hopkins hopkins has been acting since
the 1960s and he's earned two academy
awards and six nominations during his
storied career his first win came for
his iconic performance as hannibal
lecter in the best picture-winning
horror movie the silence of the lambs
his second came for his role as a man
suffering from dementia in the father
the parts couldn't be more different but
both performances are nothing less than
masterful i don't know about my mommy i
want her to come and veg me i
want to go home
the last of the original mcu avengers to
get a proper film introduction was steve
rogers in his debut film captain america
the first avenger taking place during
world war ii the film follows steve as
he joins the army and becomes the
figurehead for a super soldier program
that transforms him into the superhero
we all know today one of the military
leaders of the program is colonel
chester phillips played by tommy lee
jones tommy lee jones has been nominated
for an academy award four times he won
best supporting actor for his role as
deputy u.s marshal sam gerrard in the
1993 action film the fugitive
the final installment in the iron man
trilogy iron man 3 featured a very
controversial twist to what many people
initially perceived to be the film's
main villain in the opening moments of
the film the mandarin is set up to be
the most intense villain that tony stark
has ever faced instead the man turns out
to be trevor slattery an actor hired by
the real villain to serve as a
distraction regardless of whether or not
you think that the mandarin twist work
ben kingsley's performance was still a
highlight of iron man 3. kingsley's
acting career includes four academy
award nominations and he took home the
1983 best actor award for playing the
indian icon gandhi in the biopic of the
same name
a mid-credits scene in 2013's thor the
dark world saw the first appearance of
tanalir tivonne who goes by the alias
the collector after this cameo the
character would play a major role in
2014's guardians of the galaxy portrayed
as a man obsessed with collecting some
of the rarest artifacts in the galaxy
benicio del toro who played the
collector in all of his appearances has
been nominated for an academy award
twice both for best actor in a
supporting role in 2001 he won his first
time out for his performance as javier
rodriguez in the stephen soderbergh
crime film traffic he would get
nominated again in 2004 for his role as
ex-convict jack jordan in alejandro
gonzalez and yurito's 21 grams
2014's captain america the winter
soldier was one of the biggest films of
the mcu's phase 2 lineup it was the
first mcu film directed by the russo
brothers who would go on to direct
captain america civil war and the third
and fourth avengers films it was also
the first film to introduce the winter
soldier and the falcon who would become
fan favorite characters within the
franchise and the stars of their own
disney plus show the film saw shield
being infiltrated by the enemy
organization hydra led by the double
agent alexander pierce pierce was played
by robert redford who has been nominated
for the academy award four times in his
career he was nominated for best actor
for the sting and won best director for
his drama ordinary people which also won
best picture he would later get
nominated twice again in the best
director and best picture categories for
quiz show and received an honorary oscar
in 2002 for his career achievements
actor michael douglas has had a long and
storied career on the big screen you can
find him in some of the biggest films of
the 80s and 90s including falling down
the game basic instinct and the war of
the roses douglas has won two academy
awards over the course of his lengthy
career the first was as a producer for
one flew over the cuckoo's nest which
won all of the big five awards during
that year's ceremony douglas's second
win came when he won best actor for
playing gordon gekko in wall street a
role he would reprise in the sequel wall
street money never sleeps
well
you just rocketed into the center of the
universe pal
nowadays douglas can be seen playing dr
hank pem in the ant-man film series as
an aging scientist who develops
technology that can shrink people and
objects pym serves as a mentor for
criminal turned superhero scott lang
played by paul rudd in 1992 jonathan
lin's my cousin vinnie hit theaters
across the world the beloved comedy
follows two new yorkers who get arrested
and put on trial in rural alabama the
only lawyer that the two can rely on is
one of the new yorker's cousins who only
recently passed the bar and has no
experience working on a trial marissa
tomei plays the fiance of the lawyer
helping the friends mona lisa vito her
performance is a standout in the film
even winning her the academy award for
best supporting actress several decades
later tomei would play aunt may in the
mcu's spider-man series alongside tom
holland making her first appearance in
captain america civil war tomae is the
third person to play on may in live
action following up rosemary harris in
the toby maguire trilogy and sally field
in the andrew garfield duology it's so
hard for me to believe that she's
someone's aunt yeah well we come in all
shapes and sizes you know the mcu
features many versions of classic
characters that differ from their
original appearances the ancient one a
powerful sorcerer who serves as a mentor
to dr strange was depicted as a male in
many of the comics 2016's doctor strange
introduced a different version of the
character an androgynous guru portrayed
by tilda swinton swinton has only been
nominated for the academy award once but
once was all that she needed to win best
supporting actress for her performance
in the 2007 legal drama michael clayton
it is unclear if the ancient one will
ever return as the character didn't make
an appearance in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
australian actress kate blanchett has
been nominated for the academy award
seven times the first time she won an
oscar was for best supporting actress
for her portrayal of catherine hepburn
in martin scorsese's the aviator her
second oscar and first for best actress
came from her performance as former
socialite jasmine francis in the woody
allen comedy blue jasmine in the marvel
cinematic universe blanchett played
thor's sister hella who is released from
prison after the death of odin during
the events of thor ragnarok she serves
as the main villain of the movie
destroying thor's hammer killing the
warriors three and taking over asgard
before she's finally dispatched believe
me i would love for someone else to rule
but it can't be you you're just
the worst
taika waititi directed thor ragnarok and
voices the hilarious alien court
injecting some of his signature humor
into the fantasy film series why tt
returns to the franchise in thor love
and thunder both as director and chord
after ytt directed the mcu film he wrote
directed and starred in the historical
comedy film jojo rabbit he played an
imaginary version of adolf hitler who
tries to influence a ten-year-old boy
after he discovers a jewish girl hiding
in his house from the nazis the film was
nominated for several oscars and waititi
won the academy award for best adapted
screenplay
2018's black panther represented several
firsts for the mcu it was the first film
in the series with the predominantly
black cast and the first mcu film to be
nominated for best picture it was also
the first superhero movie overall to
receive a nomination in that category
the film features several black actors
who have both won academy awards prior
to the film and after one of those
actors was lupita nyong'o who played
black panther's partner in spy nakia
nyong'o was fortunate enough to win the
academy award for best supporting
actress in the first theatrical film she
started she won for her portrayal of
patsy in the historical drama 12 years a
slave which also won best picture
nyong'o hasn't been nominated since but
has also been busy starring as maz
kanata in the star wars sequel trilogy
and voicing raksha in the remake of the
jungle book
forest whitaker made his film debut in
1982 with both tagged the assassination
game and fast times at richmond high
since then whitaker has been in a number
of acclaimed movies one of these was the
film the last king of scotland which
centered around a doctor played by james
mcavoy who was assigned to take care of
the real-life ugandan president edie
umeen whitaker's performance as
president amin received praise from
critics and he ended up winning the
academy award for best actor when
whitaker made his mcu debut in black
panther he played the elderly states
minzuri who guided king t'challa
spiritually with the help of a special
heart-shaped herb unfortunately because
the character of zuri died during the
events of the film whitaker will not
return for black panther wakanda forever
unlike lupita nyong'o and forest
whitaker british actor daniel kaluya won
an oscar after he made his mcu debut his
performance as black panther party
chairman fred hampton the subject of the
film judas and the black messiah won him
the academy award for best supporting
actor it was the second time kaluyo was
nominated for an academy award he was
previously nominated for best actor for
his performance as chris washington in
jordan pales debut horror film get out
i can't move
you can't move
in black panther kaluya plays wakabi the
man charged with defending the borders
of the fictional kingdom of wakanda
despite initially pledging loyalty to
t'challa and being married to dora
malachi head okoye wakabi betrays both
of them and joins forces with killmonger
2019's captain marvel was the last mcu
film before the avengers team reunited
in avengers in-game bree lawson
portrayed the titular superhero also
known as carol danvers a pilot infused
with special powers who uses them to
save the alien skrulls from her former
employer the film established captain
marvel as one of the most powerful
characters in the mcu and someone who
would play a key role in future marvel
films larson has been a cast member in
several acclaimed movies but her best
work comes in the film room the picture
tells the story of ma a woman who
escapes seven years of captivity with
her young son and must adjust her life
back in the real world larson's
performance was lauded by critics and it
won her the academy award for best
actress among several other nominations
and wins
casting for a comic book adaptation
doesn't get any more perfect than j.k
simmons as daily bugle publisher jay
jonah jameson simmons ability to deliver
hilarious lines we still remember today
made him one of the best aspects of sam
raimi's spider-man trilogy in the 2000s
you don't trust anybody that's your
problem i trust my barber
in 2019 spider-man far from home simmons
reprised his role as jameson to once
again terrorize spider-man in a
completely different franchise but
simmons is much more than just jay jonah
jameson he has also been nominated for
and won several awards simmons was
recently nominated for best supporting
actor for his portrayal of william
frawley in aaron sorkins being the
ricardo's about lucille ball's
relationship with desi arnette during
the height of i love lucy he won the
oscar previously for playing the abusive
music teacher terence fletcher in damien
chazelle's whiplash
after she played a supporting role in
several different mcu films 2021's black
widow finally gave natasha romanoff the
solo movie that she deserved not only
did we get to learn more about the
character's past but we also got to meet
the other members of the family that she
had before she was trained as an
assassin and later joined the avengers
natasha's adoptive mother molina vasikov
is played by english actress rachel
weiss weiss has been nominated for the
academy award for best supporting
actress twice her first nomination which
resulted in a win was for playing tessa
abbott quail in the constant gardener
her character's murder is what main
protagonist justin quail played by rath
finds is trying to solve her second
nomination was for the favorite playing
queen anne's advisor and manipulative
love sarah churchill who battles emma
stone's abigail mashem for the queen's
approval and affection
there we go
marvel movies don't get more epic than
oscar winner chloe zhao's 2021 superhero
film eternals the film follows a group
of extraterrestrials across thousands of
years as they work to defend earth from
other alien invaders one of the core
members of the group is thina a warrior
eternal who can create weapons out of
cosmic energy dina is played by angelina
jolie who has been nominated for the
academy award twice and was even honored
with the gene herschel humanitarian
award for her work outside of film jolie
earned her academy award for her work as
psychiatric patient lisa rowe in the
drama girl interrupted winning for best
supporting actress the second time jolie
was nominated was for best actress in
changelit in this drama by clint
eastwood she plays a mother whose son
gets kidnapped only to have a different
child return to her
there are two post-credit scenes in
eternals that introduce several new
characters the first is the introduction
of harry styles arrows known as star fox
in the comics the second gives us a hint
of kit harington's black knight but
before fans are able to see more of the
character a voice from off-screen
interrupts him before the screen cuts to
black
sure you're ready for that mr whitman
that voice is our first tease of
mahershala ali's portrayal of blade a
vampire hunter previously portrayed by
western snipes in the original blade
trilogy ali has already been in the mcu
before playing the villain cottonmouth
in the luke cage series outside of his
marvel projects ali has been nominated
for and won best supporting actor twice
the first was for playing drug dealer
wan in moonlight and the second was for
playing don shirley in green book his
first win made ali the first muslim to
ever win an acting oscar
the mcu has expanded across all of time
and space so it seems only natural that
the franchise would start crossing into
different universes as well we got
glimpses of this in the disney plus show
loki but 2021 spider-man no way home
took it to the next level when peter
parker had to face off against super
villains from the past two spider-man
film series first introduced in the
amazing spider-man 2 max dillon was an
underappreciated oz corp employee before
an accident transformed him into the
super villain electro jamie foxx played
the character in his original debut
before returning to the role in no way
home fox has been nominated twice for
academy awards both in the same year his
best supporting actor nom was for
playing max the cab driver in collateral
and his best actor nom was for playing
ray charles in the biopic ray fox won
the best actor award but lost supporting
actor to morgan freeman for his
performance in million dollar baby on
march 13 2022 acclaimed actor william
hurt died at the age of 71 due to
complications from prostate cancer hurt
was nominated for the academy award four
times the first three of which were
consecutive and all being for best actor
in a leading role these films were kiss
of the spider woman which he won
children of a lesser god and broadcast
news his fourth and final nomination
came for a supporting role in david
croninberg's a history of violence in
the marvel cinematic universe hurt
played thaddeus ross originally debuting
in the incredible hulk back when edward
norton played bruce banner instead of
mark ruffalo ross was promoted from us
general to secretary of state he was one
of the driving forces behind the sokovia
accords that divided the avengers in
captain america civil war you can also
find him in avengers infinity war
avengers in game and black widow
remembered as one of the best films of
2011 the descendants is a dramedy about
an attorney who needs to make some
serious changes in his life after his
wife ends up in a coma after a boating
accident the film went on to get five
nominations at the academy awards
winning for best adapted screenplay this
would mark the second win for co-writer
and director alexander payne and the
first win for the other two co-writers
matt faxon and jim rash rash has
co-written and co-directed two other
films after the descendants alongside
faxen and also received praise for his
role as dean craig pelton in nbc's
community rash also made a brief
appearance in captain america civil war
as a staff member of mit it makes sense
considering that directors joe and
anthony russo directed several episodes
of community before jumping into the mcu
the mcu television shows on disney plus
have taken fans to many different places
one division turned the marvel universe
into a classic sitcom while loki
introduced several different versions of
the fan favorite character moon knight
offers an even wilder tale following the
multiple personalities of the titular
hero whether it's the mercenary mark
spector or museum employee steven grant
both are heavily influenced by the
egyptian god khanshu kareem al-hakim
provided the onset performance for
khanshu while f murray abraham voiced
the character you might know abraham
from homeland or the grand budapest
hotel but his most revered work happened
several years prior the 1984 film
amadeus told the story of wolf gang
amadeus mozart and his rivalry with
composer antonio salieri the latter
character was played by abraham who won
the academy award for best actor for his
performance the film would eventually go
on to win an additional seven academy
awards including best picture
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is filled with cameos and
special appearances alternate versions
of past superheroes and the mcu debut of
patrick stewart's professor charles
xavier from the x-men series one of the
film's post-credit scenes had one more
surprise up its sleeve though when all
was said and done doctor strange was
approached by the sorceress clia for a
special mission involving an incursion
that must be stopped clear was played by
charlize theron who has been nominated
for the academy award for best actress
three times she won her first nomination
for playing serial killer eileen warnos
in 2003's monster her next two
nominations came from her roles in north
country and bombshell both films telling
stories of women fighting against sexual
harassment in the workplace you've
called women you don't like
fat pigs
dogs
slobs and disgusting animals
between her work as cipher in the fast
and furious series and her potentially
big role as clia theron will definitely
be busy for a while
you can always count on english actor
christian bale to turn in a stellar
acting performance especially
considering the controversial physical
transformations he goes through for some
of these roles from the weight he gained
for his role as irving rosenfeld in
american hustle and dick cheney in vice
to the weight he lost for the machinist
in rescue don he's never been afraid to
embrace a full-body makeover the
transformations worked as he was
nominated for the academy award for best
actor for the first two bale was also
nominated for best supporting actor for
playing michael bury in the big short
and dickie eklund in the fighter winning
for the latter bale is one of the many
actors to portray batman doing so in
christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
a decade after the final film in the
trilogy was released bale has returned
to the world of superheroes as gore the
god butcher in taiko ytt's thor love and
thunder
bale and portman aren't the only big
names joining the mcu with thor love and
thunder perhaps the biggest new face is
russell crowe who will be playing the
olympian king zeus like bale crowe had
experience in dc films before making the
jump to the mcu playing superman's
father jorel and man of steel from 2000
to 2002 crow was nominated for best
actor three times he earned praise for
his roles in the insider and a beautiful
mind and he won for his role as maximus
decimus meridius in riley scott's
gladiator
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]